[Applaudissements]
vous savez pour ne plus rien rater de la
télé j'aime bien aussi aller à
l'intérieur là soit un petit peu pointu
ne cesse de rater aucun n'a fait tout
est ok extraits c'est une petite
séquence qu'on fait tous les mercredis
c'est parti regarder
[Musique]
les types de bateaux le dieu solaire à
plairait oui oui à del se déplace-t-il
la mer noire julien non pas moi une
barque une barque d'accord
[Applaudissements]
ce document est parfaitement légal et il
va bien falloir que vous l'acceptiez si
ton père était toujours en vie le rayon
de ton comportement n'ai plus envie
depuis longtemps mais s'il était encore
parmi nous il comprendrait mes
motivations millions de personnes
et je vais n'est pas l'auberge avec
benhellal car jimmy hélène ses premiers
titres q la maison depuis que katia
s'est fait kidnapper par ses ravisseurs
qui ont décidé d'enlever et je vais il
ya un ex de critiques a débarqué au
studio c'est [ __ ] sur la gueule donc
un milieu de la mafia tendance bobo
d'annecy jeu la trappe
vous croyez pas si bien dire ou de
millau lui même la camembert d'autres
aura toujours un oeil sur vous sachez le
allez je prends tout c'est un mois c'est
à moi
tribouille
sacripant laisser désamour vraiment
merci à eux merci camille combal merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]